a new variant anywhere poses
a potential threat everywhere to guard
against this danger
we must also take additional steps to
strengthen our borders
to stop those strains from entering the
uk
we've already temporarily closed all
travel corridors and we're already
requiring anyone coming into this
country
to have proof of a negative covered test
taken in the 72 hours before leaving
they must also complete a passenger
locator form which must be checked
before
they board and then quarantine on
arrival for 10 days
i want to make clear that under the
stay-at-home regulations it is
illegal to leave home to travel
abroad for leisure purposes
and we will enforce this at ports
at airports by asking people why they
are leaving and instructing them
to return home if they do not have a
valid reason
to travel we have also banned all travel
from 22 countries where there is a risk
of known variants
including south africa portugal and
south american
nations and in order to reduce the risk
posed by uk nationals and residents
returning home from these countries
i can announce that we will require all
such arrivals who cannot be refused
entry to isolate in government provided
accommodation
such as hotels for ten days without
exception
they will be met at the airport and
transported directly
into quarantine the department for
health and social care
is working to establish these facilities
as quickly as possible